[Music]
jake gyllenhaal is finally opening up
about taylor swift's 2012 song all too
well and guys he says it's not about him
i would always like to keep people on
their toes just a little refresher the
32 year old singer and the 41 year old
actor dated for several months back in
2010 and fans have long suspected that
her 2012 track all too well off her red
album was all about their relationship
the red album in its entirety was sort
of like a heartbroken person right and
you had so much better of an experience
recording at this time so what would you
then say to that taylor who wrote all
those songs i would just say i would say
that's gonna happen like there's there's
hundreds of people singing the words
well last year their one-time romance
was brought back into the spotlight with
the re-release of red taylor's version
an album which features several songs
widely thought to be about jake
including a 10-minute version of all too
well
[Music]
oh and did i mention taylor also
released a short film along with a track
starring sadie sync and dylan o'brien i
really just am so proud of those
performances and
i'm proud of how it looks and i'm proud
of how it feels to watch it and i i
really really hope the fans like it as
much as i do
well in a new profile for esquire the
nightcrawler star reacts to the grammy
winners lyrics saying quote it has
nothing to do with me
quote it's about her relationship with
her fans it is her expression artists
tap into personal experiences for
inspiration and i don't begrudge anyone
that
and without directly naming names jake
seemingly implies that his ex has a duty
to encourage her fans not to publicly
attack him in response to her music
quote at some point i think it's
important when supporters get unruly
that we feel a responsibility to have
them be civil and not allow for cyber
bullying in one's name and he adds that
all that begs for a deeper question
about taking responsibility for what we
put into the world so has jake listened
to the new version of all too well he
says no and the actor who is currently
dating model gene gdyo tells the mag
quote my life is wonderful i have a
relationship that is truly wonderful and
i have a family i love so much and this
whole period of time has made me realize
that
as for tay she's busy too making new
albums re-recording her past albums and
she's happily dating her beau actor joe
alwyn what's in the past is in the past
but we'll always have the music
[Music]